[Applause]
and eventually they'll be ai comedy
you're not immune from it no okay i love
when you say stuff like this no way
okay no way they've made
so far this has already happened yeah
they've made
uh sort of software they can write paper
you might replace
the mexicans that are making the
kitchens but you're not gonna replace
the comedians
not gonna happen so you think that
machine learning will never be capable
of understanding humor yes correct
i think not only will it be a case
because it doesn't understand anything
it doesn't understand machine learning
doesn't understand
they've done that experiment what is it
right the uh the turing test
uh yeah it's equivalent to the turing
test but it's called the something in
the box
what is it called well i don't think the
question is whether it understands the
question is whether
you know what i'm referencing the the
study that they made where they they
just
does that person speak english you're
asking them questions they have chinese
they use chinese characters and the
person in the room had like responses to
those chinese characters but they don't
really
understand chinese right they just know
how to respond right so
i don't think to answer your question i
don't think a computer will ever
understand humor
i just think it will know what is the
right thing to say
in that moment yes and then the question
is does
is understanding important
i don't think so if if you make me laugh
it doesn't matter whether you understand
it's funny or not it's going to make me
laugh
right so understand i disagree the
ability to make people laugh
maybe i mean there's certain things that
are just not formulaically funny
like there's certain things you just
cannot reproduce like you can't make
chris farley
like there's no ai that can be chris
farley there's no ai that can just say
things funny can just be funny exude
funny
there's there are i bet you ai could
write like one-liner jokes
like oh you didn't see that coming
here's like a bait-and-switch but i
don't think that they can
be funny see i think the thing that
you're
you're thinking that it can't predict
new things like chris farley was a new
thing sure he had references and stuff
like that there's a little bit of like
uh belushi in him there's a few other
things but it was his own version that
was
perfect for that particular moment in
time
so what a i can't do is sort of predict
what people will like because it's
pulling from previous
information but what it can do is it can
iterate
infinitely whereas an individual can
only integrate uh
within a few concepts of time what what
i would say is
yes 100 right but what i what farley did
let's say it was unique or not unique
it was personality driven right and i
don't think ai will have enough
personality to be funny off of
personality we've all had friends like
like our boy mike right mike is funny
mike from modern builds
mike from modern bill shout out to mike
formatted us we love mike tippy toe mike
and mike is so funny but mike might not
say a joke that's funny
he will just exist as funny he will just
be funny how do you replicate that ai
you cannot
so you can create that with ai you can
do it through brute force now the
question would be whether or not ai
could ever make a popular comedian
ai could simulate comedy but they might
have to simulate so many versions to get
it right
that that creates an unwieldy burden
that someone would have to curate to
figure out what's actually going to pop
so i think it's possible in the creation
i'm not sure that that creation aspect
because they cause an ai can create
things simultaneously at the same time
yeah so with like the kitchen design as
an architect and designer
i can only do one design at a time the
software can do every design
at the same time yeah now the question
is
too many designs is actually not useful
to the consumer
so it could write every single possible
joke but what it might not be able to do
is then surface the most probable ones
so it's not the generative things that
are impossible it's maybe it's like it
generates so much that it creates this
infinite mess that can't be navigated so
it'll actually surface the things that
are going to work to the audience sure
so it could it could generate like a
thousand different possibilities and you
have to work through a thousand
different one to find the one and it
wouldn't know which th
which one it is because it doesn't feel
and it doesn't understand what we feel
like so yeah so much of comedy is like
this feeling that we have that we know
is wrong um
but is relatable so how does an ai
develop a feeling that they know is
right or they don't understand right or
wrong
and they don't understand relatability
they just develop the different kids it
would be if they could make
a audience ai that then interfaces with
the comedian ai
and if they studied enough audience
members and been like oh these people
laugh at this
if they could create enough thing where
then that audience could do an infinite
number of sets then you have accelerated
evolution
and that's where you're really in
trouble i think that that could create
a woke comedian like that could create
like a like a williamsburg
like uh comic book store comedian like
i'm gonna tell
that's really what that type of comedy
is i think that's why i hate it so much
is that i'm just going to tell people
the thing that they want to hear
and i'm going to be clever about it
instead of telling people the thing that
they
feel that they might not even want to
feel but we all feel and we relate to
and then making that fun why does that
bother you so much though like
i've heard you sort of talk it just
annoys you but you're not like an
unprogressive person you're like a kind
and thoughtful person to the people that
are sort of in your life
but you're so offended in a visceral
world i'm not progressive in my comedy
yeah i don't believe in progress is it
the performative part that just kind of
irks you
yeah it's mixing that in with something
that's supposed to be
for this other thing yeah it's you're
taking advantage of it
it's kind of like uh like food is art
like kind of a thing
like oh here's this delicious seafoam
yeah it's like though because i'm so
devoid from like making food
i'm like so removed from it that i can
appreciate that
like i can watch what is that a
restaurant in chicago that they did
yeah yeah like most i imagine foodies
would look at that and be like why are
you making
bubbles out of food like get over it but
i'm such a chimp i'm just like
bubble food it floats cool let's go beth
so yeah yeah i if i just love comedy and
i love the authenticity and comedy and
obviously all the people that i care
about within kami are super authentic
and i try to be authentic so when i see
it
done in a fraudulent way i
just don't relate to it as much yeah but
you're you're
it's hack architecture yeah that's
that's what it's like
somebody making this architecture that
you know is like super hack
and you probably look at you like this
is easy this is hack
i know what you're [ __ ] doing here
yeah imagine they presented it
as if it was the most exquisite
beautiful art you've ever seen in your
life so for me to think that like i'm
i think sustainability is really
important but the thing that would
always irk me is when people be like
i put solar panels on this house and
it's now sustainable and it's like look
that's a good thing
yeah it's great solar panels are awesome
technology it's really cool to own your
energy source and a way to like
take money that was going to a utility
bill and increase the value of your home
and you actually own
your own means of production that's
awesome but it's like
it's so additive it's not like artistic
it's not necessarily
integrated it's not thoughtful it's just
like
it's additive brownie points in this
sort of sustainability
arena and it's not necessarily good
integrated design
so as a design as a designer you're like
i don't like the aesthetic
yeah but as someone who cares about the
environment you're like all right that's
cool you're trying to do something
yeah it's it's easy to add something
that's like a badge of goodness right
it's true signaling is that your issue
it's the same thing with like yeah it's
the same thing with like uh
and i think virtue is actually a good
thing yeah but the signal part
the signal part could actually be
signaling real virtue yeah i don't have
a problem with virtue signaling
i have a problem with disproportionate
signaling
and a small amount of virtue if the
virtue is huge
and the signal's small yeah good job
if the signal's [ __ ] huge and the
virtue is like
just slightly above the bare minimum
yeah yeah you're not doing much
you're taking the easy way out for the
highest reward
right and that is my issue with that
type of comedy
we both know it's funny not you and i
i'm saying like
comedians we all know it's funny if
you're a funny person you know it's
funny
if you're not a funny person you
probably know it's funny we all know the
easiest way out
we all know what will succeed you know
if i'm opening up a restaurant i know
the thing that's going to sell right
but if i'm going to try to push it i'm
trying to get you to eat a parsnip and
i'm going to put extra love and care
into that [ __ ] parsnip and make it so
good you actually order a parts
parsnip i go to that chef i'm like bro i
can't believe you made me order a
vegetable like it was a steak
you are nice with it but the guy who's
just like
here's [ __ ] what is it what is the
most common thing right now here's uh
duck fat french fries or something like
that like
you're not being unique right with your
duck fat french fries you're playing the
hits you're playing the hits yeah you're
karaoke
exactly there you go
you